hace cinco meses que Marian continúa sus
estudios en la sala de su casa después
de que los talibanes prohibieran la
educación Universitaria a las niñas esta
ex estudiante universitaria de 21 años
recibe clases de inglés en su teléfono a
través de WhatsApp según el calendario
hoy tienes que trabajar la gramática las
instrucciones sean mediante mensajes
fotos videos y notas de voz paga el
equivalente a 5 dólares al mes por el
curso además tiene que pagar una
conexión a internet débil y cara
Este es un vídeo que me ha enviado la
profesora pero no puedo descargarlo
porque la conexión a internet es muy
mala lo único que puedo descargar son
mensajes de voz
cuando estudiaba en la universidad Tenía
muchos sueños y esperanzas pensaba que
continuaría mis estudios pero hoy no
tengo ninguna Esperanza
como muchas otras mujeres afganas en las
redes sociales pide ahílon musk see you
spacex y propietario de Twitter que
ponga su servicio de internet por
satélite starlink a disposición de
Afganistán Como hizo en Ucrania e Irán
esta petición de las mujeres afganas a
elon musk que está motivada por el hecho
de que muchas de nosotras no tenemos
acceso a internet a veces es por los
problemas económicos que tiene nuestras
familias apoyó esta petición Y si nos
respondieran positivamente Me alegraría
mucho
los talibanes afirman que las jóvenes
podrán volver a estudiar algún día sin
embargo exigen la segregación total en
los centros educativos según el director
de una universidad privada será una
tarea difícil que aumentará los gastos
de la universidad
tenemos problemas financieros porque un
tercio de los estudiantes no están
principios de curso no pudimos
matricular a ninguna mujer
en el mejor de los casos Si seres
autoriza a volver en algún momento
estarán en un edificio separado en
clases separadas con profesores
exclusivos lo que aumentará aún más
nuestros gastos
[Música]
por ahora las afganas no tienen más
opciones que estudiar en casa o en
escuelas secretas